hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
they just announced that our Erie
Williams is taking the mantle of Ironman
this fall so I'm gonna explain what's
going on it's all part of Marvel's civil
war arc it's just like the Falcon
becoming Captain America so in order to
explain what's going on it's actually
really exciting but there's a whole
bunch of new stuff going on with the
Tony Stark character so I'm gonna have
to talk about Civil War two I'm gonna
have to talk about what's going on in
his Avengers books and what's going on
in this invincible Iron Man title so
just careful for spoilers for that it's
actually really exciting so one Tony
Stark has discovered that Howard Stark
is not his biological father you know
mind blown
they're still pursuing that storyline we
have no idea who it is to Rhodey has
just died during this big Civil War blow
up with the new Ulysses inhuman who can
predict the future that conflict hasn't
reached fever pitch yet it's just
started to blow up and everyone's faces
so Tony Stark is still very much the
Iron Man character but what they're
teasing is is that the end of the Civil
War arc he'll have a reason to step away
from the mantle and like officially pass
it on to riri Williams that's why she's
wearing this costume this is really
preview cover art for what's going to be
happening this fall so like you're not
going to see her wearing the actual Tony
Stark Ironman looking armor for a long
time for the meantime they're just going
to be using the next couple of months
civil war in this invincible Iron Man
title to kind of set her character up
explain who she is what it is about her
that makes Tony Stark so curious so the
interesting thing like the introduction
that Ben Dez gave her is very fitting
it's kind of like the Iron Man cave
scene where they throw him and tell him
to create a weapon and then when they
come pounding to kill him later he opens
the door and it's like surprise
Iron Man mark 1 armor so that's
basically the introduction that they
gave her she had reverse-engineered one
of our man's old armors here we'll call
this the Optimus Prime revision but
she's in her dorm in MIT she's a 15 year
old prodigy just like Tony Stark he was
also a 15 year old MIT student so
already they're telling you that she's
just as smart if not smarter than Tony
Stark if she was able to do this on her
own
without any of his resources and she's
kind of like this wayward teenager from
a very poor family attending MIT on a
genius scholarship so she reverse
engineer
Tony Stark's Iron Man armor from scratch
and then because it causes like such a
problem for the campus the people are
banging on the door like you haven't
been at class for several weeks we're
getting ready to kick you out they open
the door to carry her off and you get
the surprise it's okay I think
I'm done with school so very fitting
introduction after that she takes the
armor first been like oh my god this is
so much fun okay let's try and do some
superhero stuff so she tries to capture
a couple criminals and she's able to
take them down but it fractures her
armor so she derps in the way that Tony
Stark derps the first time he's creating
his new armor and just as he does
something really awesome boom they take
the piss out of it the armor fractures
so it's a very familiar introduction to
like a very new twist on the Iron Man
mythos so right now the big macro arc
that's going on is this Civil War two
conflict in the Minority Report inhuman
all this other stuff is going on with
the characters
so right now riri williams is like this
small B story Tony Stark's life is
imploding all around him he's got all
these problems to take care of his
company is almost bankrupt so he's got
to fix his company he's got to figure
out what's going on with his true
biological parents and he's got to solve
this conflict with Captain Marvel over
the Minority Report inhuman so you can
understand how he might want to step
away from the day-to-day of being Iron
Man and just passed that on to reroute
Williams in the fall so even though it
seems like they're going to kill Iron
Man at the end of Civil War - in the way
that they killed Captain America at the
end of the first Civil War I don't think
that's the way that things are going to
go down that would be completely
unsatisfying if they just completely
recycled the ending from Civil War one
so like you have the idea of the all-new
all-different Avengers but it's really
Tony Stark at the head of that but he's
got all this other stuff going on so
really it seems like he's just gonna
step away from the day-to-day of being
Iron Man continue to fund this all-new
all-different Avengers and spend more
time trying to fix his company doing
really cool things being a billionaire
genius philanthropist playboy and you
have to remember that Mary Jane Watson
is also his assistant now which is also
kind of a new twist on a couple
different characters because he has this
really funny relationship with
spider-man who he himself is a little
bit more like Tony Stark now because he
has Parker Industries so now is a really
good time to be reading Spider
an Iron Man in civil war if you haven't
been reading those titles it's really
just starting to ramp up now you have to
think of the big Civil War arc like this
big overarching conflict as the signpost
that kind of chart the timeline and then
all this other stuff is going on in the
spin-off titles so just expect to learn
more about the riri Williams character
and how her relationship with Tony Stark
evolved in the next couple of months
because he knows that she exists he has
like his own version of Google Alerts
for his Iron Man tech so like if
anywhere in the world
someone were to use his tech he would
know about it so he instantly knows
about her but he isn't really thinking
about her he's like he's one of those
people that has a billion different
things going on in his brain at once and
he's really good at getting distracted
so just expect that to blow up in his
face literally so naturally you have the
riri character who's like waiting on the
bench he's like I have the talent and
the willingness this is the only thing I
want to do I have this one thing that I
want to do let me do it so Iron Man's
like okay I have like billion things
that I need to do so why don't you sub
in for me so I can fix all this other
that I have going on in my life
but the way Bendis teased it was a
little bit more funny like Tony Stark
taking an interest in this new girl like
who this is really cool maybe I should
buy her out just thinking like a
businessman so even if you're absolutely
confused by what the hell is going on
during this Iron Man title like if
you've been following Civil War but
you're not really sure about what's
going on an Iron Man the artwork is
fantastic so be sure to check it out
he's also really funny to hear all the
spider-man jokes when Tony Stark is
talking to Mary Jane Watson like it's
very tongue-in-cheek like she definitely
acknowledges that she and Peter has
history but they've rebooted the
continuity a little bit since secret
Ward's so their backstory is a little
bit complicated they're a little
mysterious about it which I kind of like
it leaves it open to interpretation like
is a fan you know all about Peter Parker
and Mary Jane's history in the comics so
when Tony Stark is like do you know
Peter Parker and she's like yeah we we
have history you kind of laugh to
yourself and think about 50 plus years
of comic book history like oh yeah yeah
a little bit history there so be sure to
check it out I mean it just happens to
be Wednesday new comics day so that
tends to be when they drop a bunch of
big news about this so RiRi Williams is
still a relatively small plot point
inside the Iron Man comic they're still
setting her character up this is just
hilarious scene with Tony Stark and
Rodion for
before rody ends up dying so this is
earlier in the timeline but Friday his
AI ping salmon is like you know there's
a 15 year old girl flying around in your
armor and he's just like hey what
so the invincible Iron Man comic is a
little bit behind the main Civil War
title but it's really funny like I
really do enjoy what Bendis is trying to
do with the characters I'm totally cool
with them passing the mantle from
character to character like Falcon
becoming the new Captain America we'll
see if this new Iron Man sticks but
presumably for most of 2017 that's going
to be status quo like she will
metaphorically and literally be wearing
the mantle for most of 2017 maybe
through 2018 I think it just depends on
how well the title sells like female
Thor was kind of gimmicky when it
initially debuted but it sold so many
more issues continuously than the old
regular Thor comic so Marvel's like okay
clearly people like female Thor so we're
just going to keep doing that so this is
really only like a monthly title so
what's probably going to happen is this
is I do civil war videos I might touch
on this just a little bit but I will be
doing a few more comic book videos this
summer like DC rebirth Marvel Civil War
there's a lot of really cool stuff
happening this summer so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and in other
related summer goings on
I have a one-punch video that I'm going
to post next there's some really cool
one-punch news so I'll be posting that
later today while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for all my other Marvel comic books
Civil War videos that are going on right
now and you can click here to learn all
about the game of thrones' or Ahai
prophecy thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you